I think that doctoral programs in in
business and all these disciplines share
a lot of features with doctoral programs
in most disciplines which is you're
going to spend the first couple years
taking coursework learning the core
kinds of theories and methods in your
discipline some programs have everyone
do some general requirements across the
board regardless of your discipline and
then more detailed in-depth field
requirements other programs you kind of
go right into your field so that's an
important difference to think about
after two years of coursework or usually
by the end of two years of coursework
there will be an exam and every
university has an exam whether it's
called a comprehensive exam a qualifying
exam a field exam and this exam is
essentially measuring your comprehensive
understanding of the major theories and
methods in your field after that point
students really start beginning
transitioning into research and although
sometimes there can be some tentative
wading into research in earlier years
usually by the third year is when
students are really transitioning from
kind of taking a lot of courses to
actually doing research and then
eventually kind of producing their own
knowledge whether that starts as
collaborative research with faculty or
some of your other colleagues in the
program and then gradually moves into
your own research where it starts with
independent research there are lots of
different ways that that can happen and
a lot of its dependent upon both the
program and your your individual
discipline so that takes you to cut a
year three and usually your three and
four and and and five are spent kind of
figuring out and doing what your own
research project or projects are and
eventually producing a piece of original
work in the form of a dissertation and
and the forms and formats of
dissertations vary but typically there
are two or three papers on either a
related stream of research or two or
three kind of pieces that that you've
done during that
time period once you've kind of
transitioned in the research and usually
that program and that experience
culminates in either an oral exam of
some kind in some places it's called the
dissertation defense so that format kind
of varies also by program as well and
usually most of your fifth year and most
people can finish these programs in five
years is spent on the job market so
going out there getting your research
out there talking about it with other
people and other schools and ideally
landing a great job at the conclusion
admissions criteria again there's
there's variance among programs but
basically we want everyone everyone
needs to have an undergraduate degree
there's no graduate degree required
although some people do enter programs
with graduate study whether it's a
master's degree in MBA in some cases we
have students that have a doctorate in
another field who are transitioning into
one of our disciplines but it's not
required usually a standardized test
score GRE exam in some cases GMAT exam
in some cases this is another thing
you're gonna want to check because those
requirements vary from school to school
letters of recommendations and a
personal statement and a personal
statement is really a way for you to
tell the admissions committee kind of
what brought you to this point what
you're interested in in studying and why
this particular school and program is a
good fit for you I'm gonna wrap it up
but we can talk more in the QA but the
one thing I would say is that the
question I get asked a lot is you know
what should I be looking for in a
program and the advice I always give
students is you want to really do your
homework go to each school that you're
interested in see what the faculty in
your program and in your discipline are
doing read their CDs read papers they're
working on see working papers see what
students many of whom have their own
websites out there are working on in
that probe
and ultimately look for places where
there are a number of people who you
think are doing work that's interesting
to you and or who could support the kind
of work that you want to do and add
value to it I think the wrong strategy
is to find and fixate on one person who
you think may be and may be in fact a
superstar in the field and kind of throw
all your chips in with that one person
that's a really big gamble so I'm going
to turn it over to not Thank You doctors
professor admati why academia can you
tell us a little bit about the
contribution to business practice you
know the financial rewards the lifestyle
I think when you think of academic
career and I know I've been in this
career for almost thirty years I started
a ph.d program I think it's hard to
think of a job that has more autonomy
and more freedom to a person where you
actually do not on a day-to-day basis
have a boss and you really can follow a
lot of your own urges and interests and
control a lot of your day to day
activities the biggest freedom you have
is the research freedom to think about
things that you think are interesting
that you grab maybe that you want to
know the answer to and that's that's an
amazing freedom that that and then
academic usually has we we're not
usually told what to do research on we
are informed by the fields and by our
own understanding of what needs to be
done next or what we think we can do
next ourselves and how we can contribute
there's a lot of things you can choose
within the job so you can really tailor
it to your own pace some people like to
work with other people some people like
to work alone there is even when you
teach which
was do you control a lot of what do you
what you teach and also within the
course how you present the materials
what how to sequence the material a lot
of that it's just your own view and your
own decision sometimes you discuss this
with other people but you really have a
lot of autonomy even who you teach where
there it's MBA some schools have you can
choose a school sometimes accordingly
some schools have undergrad programs
some have active PhD programs which
level you choose to teach it's often
time at least partly influenced by what
you like to teach what you enjoyed it
teaching what you're good at later in a
career like that some people choose to
mix it with other things like they write
books sit on boards they can consult
there's a lot of flexibility there to
kind of go one day a week or some level
to to do this I should also mention some
people teach executives in some of these
programs so schools have that but it's
optional whether you teach there or not
often time it's just an extra thing that
you choose to do sometimes people will
only do it later in the career because
of a lot of research requirements
earlier on you can travel in this job to
conferences and people do more of it
than than others some people like the
conference's that I have near ski
resorts and other people avoid them like
me because I don't ski
you have advising relationships with
students especially PhD students and
that's very satisfying part of the of
their job as well and some people have
more of it than others but that's again
part of your your autonomy and you'll
have a some flexibility with respect to
your work hours often time you don't
teach all quarters certainly research is
flexible some people are morning force
people's and people are night people but
I like especially for the the bulk of
the first decade or two in this job and
often time at appearance of time within
the job I like a colleague of mine once
telling somebody that this is an
extremely flexible job you can work any
80 hours a week
so it is how to work often time and
sometimes I in the very beginning of my
career remember what walking out of the
building and the problem I'm thinking
about is like I can't think of anything
else because it's I'm really obsessed
with you know solving that problem or
finding the proof or whatever and I
remember looking at like faculty
assistants going home and Wow
you know they're done they don't take
their work home with them like I do so
there is that it really can be you know
people can become alcohol it can not
have a balance but but it's again in
your hands they have to have the balance
the other thing I would say is that it's
an exciting job because it's it's always
interesting and it's always new you can
always learn a new subject so leave a
research area that you kind of get tired
of off and kind of feel like you've said
what you said and then move to some
other area then when you do do the
research if you're lucky you make a
difference in this research you create a
no idea that other people then proceed
with and you feel like you made a little
difference on to the research and then
eventually trickling down to to maybe
the practice even our understanding of
how systems work or how how to
understand various processes within
within business now in terms of
lifestyle I would say it's not a job
where you usually become extremely rich
but it's a fairly webpage job some
people if they really enjoyed said I
can't believe that it can be to do this
so but you know it is work but but if
you like it and if you're a good fit for
it it is it is what paid for for for
that kind of thing if you really enjoy
but that's true for every job that you
enjoy probably also within Business
School's I would say that you we are
lucky because business schools tend to
the business schools that are research
oriented tend to have
resources for research quite big and so
we don't end up spending a lot of our
time writing grants and depending on
soft money for for research because
we're very well supported to to go to
conferences to get datasets to have the
time in the summer to do research and
and and all of that to have research
assistants all the stuff that that we
need so and then the other thing about
this career is that in most places we
have this wonderful invention called
tenure systems which basically the way
it works is you get an initial contract
for working and it's usually a few years
so it's not like it's gonna be over in a
year or anything you do have a little
time and then it gets renewed you get
reviewed depending on your research and
and other things you might you will
hopefully get it extended for a few more
years meanwhile all this time there's
some kind of a clock that's ticking and
it's called the tenure clock and that
system which could be seven years
sometimes more sometimes less is
sticking with the sort of up route
system where at some point you get
reviewed and if you do make it through
that system the clock stops ticking and
at that point you really have a lot of
flexibility and the nice thing about
that is that you do not have to you can
really go deeply into research subject
and you can take some chances with that
and that is the idea behind this system
it's not just to give us job security
it's it's to allow us to to be bold in
our research and it's sort of rewards
innovation I had a PhD student every you
write a paper on them on how on how this
kind of system encourages people to take
to take leaps in their research and try
and allow themselves to fail sometimes
as well so you if the system has enough
enough flexibility to allow that you
have the time the luxury of time which
you wouldn't have in consulting jobs or
other policy job of course in in sort of
on a trading desk in Wall Street where
everything is just on a minute and even
if you do research it's just under a lot
a lot of pressure and then in terms of
lifestyle as well I'd say the
flexibility is very nice
it's nice for families faculty often
time can coach Little League and do
these stunts kinds of things that allow
some balance in their lives and their
choice do it that way thank you
research obviously is a significant part
of a career in academia and as a
doctoral students a Baba perhaps you can
tell us what type of research is being
done in a business school what's it like
let me start off by saying what it is
not like okay when I joined the ph.d
program at Duke I'd only worked for six
years at an MBA so I was one of the late
bloomers so to speak I mean I was 31
when I joined the ph.d program and I had
no clue this is before the age of the
internet 91 is when I joined you and I
thought a ph.d program is all about
you know I'll become an expert as a
marketer and I can give advice and
douleur advice to people now why wait
until they become a CEO in 10 years I
can do that in five years not be doing
advice and turned out it is completely
wrong yeah it is it is very research
oriented there's no difference between
what not does and I do Eric does and in
terms of being the business school was
just being in social sciences I mean you
argue and the economics group will be
doing the same kind of research so I
mean the research becomes extremely
important in fact I would say that not
talking about tenure those of you who
think that you wanted you wanted to get
into academia because you want to be a
teacher you want to teach I mean that's
what that's that's where your a thing is
you've got to be you're going to be
disappointed in the sense that all the
evaluation criteria appears until you
make tenure which I talked about will be
based on on research I mean teaching
matters but it's predominantly going to
be based on research in fact the letters
of evaluation that are going to come
from outside evaluating your you know
candidacy to tenure
will often involve people who are not in
the field they're not in business
schools they've been the social science
already psychologists economists and so
on so that was that was a the major kind
of thing I wanted to kind of share with
you so so that is one now how are we
different from the social sciences well
- or not pointed out I mean we get paid
a lot more money believe me I mean
relatively speaking we can all paid a
lot more money and we don't have the
right brands which they have to do so we
get it gives us a lot more time having
said that there is lot more teaching
that is involved but the teaching in the
sense that because you start teaching
MBAs at some point in time in your
careers you start teaching MBAs
executives and so on which for me is a
lot of fun because it's a great way for
me to interact with people in the real
world environment and I'll talk about
one research idea that I was I worked on
that actually came from an excited
program that I was teaching the spark of
the idea came from there but it is in
this thing so for example this
particular quarter is my teaching
quarter and as an odd set I get done
with teaching in ten weeks the rest of
the year I could be anywhere I want in
the world no one is going to ask me
anything and that's the flexibility that
that comes with thing and of course with
10 you anyway so yeah so there's going
to be the teaching element involved it's
gonna be much more intense unlike the
many of you have been in other programs
undergraduate programs where the teacher
can come in and just literally read off
a sheet of paper or you know on notes
and you cannot do that out here so it's
a little bit more deeply involved that's
probably why we get paid more anyway so
in terms of an example of a research
idea right I mean so think you think
about the kind of research so this was
an idea where be now it is now called
the priced recibo effect some of you
might already heard about this was came
from this observation that I had that
you know one way by which you can build
a comparative advantage that is you make
sure that the consumer buys your product
compared to the competitors product or
the easiest way to do that is reduce
prices right you you either reduced
prices permanently or you give an
incentive in the form of rebates and
coupons and discounts
on and I would ask these people for
example I would ask executives at Dell
and they used to come and I was at
University of Iowa they would come over
there and I'll ask them aren't you
worried that if you keep lowering your
prices because you're a classic price
leader that's surprised leadership
strategy the adopting aren't you worried
that it will negatively hurt perceptions
about your product well we do know that
reduce prices is going to hurt
perceptions and their argument was yes
it is going to hurt perceptions but
someone is going to use our computer and
a computer is a good quality and
therefore it isn't the market foot
places product for itself why I'm going
to use the computer I'm going to
discover that it is a good quality and
I'm going to blog I'm going to
communicate to my friends and it is a
good quality and that is the question
that I wanted to challenge is it
possible that it is not just a matter of
perception that if you think a product
is not good the product itself will be
not good right so a good example of the
study I'm a psychologist so if I divide
this room into how am i doing in time I
can keep talking all the time I like
talking about that as you can be tense
you can tell so let us say I'm going to
divide this this this group into into
two groups
so the between subject design so what
I'm going to do to this half is not
aware to this happen vice versa so I'm
going to have you tell you that this is
a study about energy drinks like Red
Bull and this is consumed in
undergraduate in campuses so on college
campuses
you know before exams when people want
to be alert because of the caffeine and
amino acids and so on and I'm but I'm
going to tell you that we don't know
about the efficacy of these of these
drinks so this whole study is about the
efficacy of these drinks and what I want
to do is I'm going to have you guys buy
this drink from me at a full price
regular price of dollar 89 for example
and you will buy this from me at a
discounted price so you'll pay an 89
cents I will tell you what is the full
price but I'll tell you that you're
getting this discount only because we
got an institutional discount and I'm
passing it on to you that's all you're
going to consume the drink and you'll
end up solving a series of word jumble
puzzles so you have 15 puzzles to be
solved in 30 minutes and the question I
am be asking here is that is it possible
that the number of puzzles that you will
end up solving would be different than
the number of persons are you will end
up solving and is it possible that you
folks will put in more effort into the
task the new folks and that's indeed
what we found
in other words what we show here in this
study series of studies and we are now
moved into so as in the introduction
they said I'm video neuroscience
research right so one of the other
questions is that think about the
category of wine I mean huge range of
prices people will swear even the
experts will swear the connoisseurs want
experts will swear that the higher the
price the better its experience and so
the question we ask is is it true if you
put people into a magnet that is a
functional magnetic resonance imaging
machine and we can monitor the activity
in the brain is it possible that if it
is a higher priced one albeit
unbeknownst to you it is the same wine
that is being delivered into your mouth
you don't know that but it is a higher
price what you think is a higher price
point is it possible that certain area
of the brain that code for pleasure will
be more active then if it is a lower
price wine and that's what we found so
you see the kind of pattern Arisa the
question basic question came from an
interesting kind of issue in the real
world and typically that's how the the
business most most research and business
will have that angle to it but we still
publish in the same journals I mean you
can take a journal like oddly leading
general journal of consumer research you
have Journal of Personality and Social
Psychology was reading journal in
psychology you don't know that I where
that's coming from
you literally take the thing you can't
tell the difference between those two
it'll be almost identical so we do
exactly what they do
except you know it's going to have a
slightly business-oriented angle to that
thank you
Eric from a student perspective can you
tell us what it's like what you learn
I'm your experience sure first welcome
to all of you guys you know when I heard
how many people were going to be here
today I gave a lot of thought about what
I would say in some of the range of
topics but regardless of where I let my
mind wander I always came back to the
same point which is that I really love
the ph.d program here at Stanford I
really love it but that doesn't mean
that it's right for everyone and I don't
want you guys to think that the reason
I'm up here today is simply to trumpet
the the virtues of attending Stanford
but rather I'm hoping to provide you
guys with some perspective as to what
you guys may actually encounter should
you ultimately enroll in the program so
broadly speaking that the GSB as you may
be able to tell thus far is it's a
lot of things it's interdisciplinary
it's an exciting place to do research
but it's also very challenging for
students the workload is I would
describe it as intense and I'm sure
that's something that you guys have
heard elsewhere but in its most likely
more rigorous than you're accustomed to
at the undergraduate level it requires a
lot of discipline and it requires a lot
of focus during my first couple years
here when I was taking classes I worked
you know every you know Monday through
Friday many hours and I worked most
weekends as well and of course this will
vary depending upon the program but
certainly for my experience have
required a lot of work and that's not to
scare you off it's just to provide you
with the perspective as to what you may
expect some people will may be thinking
about enrolling in a in a ph.d program
as a way to continue the undergraduate
lifestyle that you've become so
accustomed to you know I don't recommend
that really you know the people who do
well in the ph.d program obviously you
know it takes a lot of brains but I
think more than anything that requires a
lot of hard work and dedication that's
something that you want to make sure
that you have but also conveyed to the
admissions committee that that's
something that you know is special about
you I would say that one of the great
things that makes all that hard work
possible and and often times enjoyable
is that the Stanford GSB is a it's not
only introduced upon area but it's also
a very cooperative environment in the
sense that you know there's something
about being here at Stanford or the GSB
that makes people people seem to be in a
good mood maybe it's being here at
Stanford or do they typically very nice
weather but it really breeds a good
sense of cooperation among the students
which helps a tremendous amount in
getting a very broad array of
perspectives to help you with to solve
problems one of the things you'll learn
here is that it's so important to be
able to learn from other bright
individuals who don't necessarily come
from the same background that you do it
really helps a lot in terms of solving
problems and open your eyes to things
that you would not have normally thought
about so in addition to things that you
may also learn that the program is that
there is a tremendous distinction
between undergraduate and graduate
courses in this
that my experience as an undergraduate
was that there was more of an emphasis
on things like memorization and basic
principles whereas at the graduate level
you really need to have a very strong
concept of understanding of precision
and higher analytical reasoning and
creativity those are the things that
really gonna help separate the people
who do well in the program versus those
who do not
you'll learn to think like an academic
and this is both good and bad I think
you know you learn to think like an
academic not only for for research
purposes but it changes the way that you
see everyday normal day-to-day things
like you'll think about the world
differently in terms of statistical
inference and incentive structures and
and of course rhetoric and discourse I
remember a couple months ago I was
watching television with some of my
friends who aren't PhD students and
there was this mountain Dew commercial
that came on and it mentioned that said
you know fact men are three times more
likely to be hit by lightning that women
and just is a very visceral reaction I
just belted out in a very measured and
credulous tone oh you didn't control for
a self-selection and the people who look
my friends were looking at their state
of sitting next to me they were looking
at me you know as if I was a very big
nerd and that's probably true but it's
something that like you go to be
accustomed to and that's sort of the way
that it changes your thinking is a very
powerful and wonderful concept and once
you realize you know you'd learn to
embrace the the the change and the way
that you think about the world you know
when you get to learn from the world's
experts on these subject it's it's a
really wonderful feeling so in case I
sold you or they've sold you on the
merits of applying to a ph.d program and
you guys feel that you're ready a couple
of things that I would recommend in
terms of the application process is it
it's so important that you figure out
that the program is right for you and by
that I mean speak to faculty and
administrators speak to current students
I think current students will give you a
real strong indication as to what you're
going to expect in your individual
program figure out that the structure of
the program and figure out if people are
happy there
I don't say that simply because I'm
happy here but when I was on the the in
your position a couple years ago I
visited schools and I talked to students
at various places and I got the sense
that there was a lot of variation in
terms of where people were happy and
that makes a big difference because the
the general collective mood of the
community it has a lot of you know
ripple effects not only in terms of how
people interact with each other but
certainly the cooperation amongst
students and I'll say this wallet varies
a tremendous amount across individual
programs for programs like economics and
finance and accounting there's a central
emphasis on mathematics and analytical
reasoning that often separates you know
the people who had you know basic
undergraduate training versus those
people who are ready to make the leap
towards a higher level of graduate
training this of course varies from
program to program but I found that it
makes a very big difference and making a
smooth transition if you had you know if
you've thought about these concepts and
have this sort of basic background it's
certainly not required but I think from
my perspective it's helpful I think the
earlier you can start to identify
research interests or at least things
that you find interesting the better off
you'll be the more you can start to talk
to professor's at individual programs
about how your research interests online
with theirs I think that's something
that's helpful to make sure that you're
the right fit for the program but also
to convey to the professor's that you're
thinking about these broader issues and
as many as everyone has mentioned today
getting your PhD out of Business School
is a major major undertaking and it's
important that when you apply to
programs it's important that you
identify or and you understand the
sacrifices that are required and it's
important that when you write your
letters of rec I'm sorry write your
letters of your yeah yeah your state
your personal statement letters that you
think very hard not only that to
demonstrate to people that you recognize
the sacrifice that's required but also
that you know what you're making the
sacrifice for that is you know what
you're striving for and then what's you
know keeping you focused in the program
I can offer a lot of different
perspective as to what it's like here at
Stanford I can't speak to every
individual program but as I mentioned
you know I absolutely love love the
program here and I'm glad to answer any
questions you guys have thank you Eric